[Música]
imaginar a una niña pequeña ella estaba
entrenando muy duro para poder jugar un
nacional de voleibol este siempre ha
sido uno de sus más grandes sueños ella
se encuentra con su equipo a punto de
jugar la final del regional está a un
paso de lograr aquello que es anhelado
tanto dentro del auditorio hay muchas
personas apasionadas fuera de él hay un
cielo despejado y soleado parece un día
perfecto
pero hay un problema ella no se puede
concentrar lo único en lo que puede
pensar es que en cualquier momento todo
puede llegar a salir mal
se imagina secuestros aviones cayendo
del cielo que olvida todo lo que estamos
practicando por años
y con esto se paraliza
entra al partido en casi en automático y
aunque por un momento llega a disfrutar
lo que es jugar es regional todos estos
pensamientos siguen en su mente
esa niña era yo a los 14 años
en el momento pensé que mis pensamientos
negativos eran por los nervios digo
porque más es que alguien se paraliza
justo antes de pelear por cumplir sus
sueños
esa fue la primera vez que me di cuenta
que mis pensamientos eran completamente
pesimistas a pesar de ser una persona
alegre y enérgica la mayoría del tiempo
había algo que siempre me empujaba a
imaginar el peor caso posible no tengo
idea si fueron los maratones de 'mentes
criminales' a los 10 o si fueron las
películas de suspenso a los 2 pero esta
sombra siempre me seguía sigue en la
calle en el coche con mi familia
imaginaba que tocaríamos si alguien iba
tarde con a una reunión conmigo
imaginaba que me abandonaría
siempre eran situaciones que me parecían
100 factible estén en un momento y
completamente ridículas al siguiente
desde que tengo memoria siempre he
querido que mi vida sea como una serie o
una película no solo porque te muestran
con cosas super fantásticas pero porque
siempre tienen finales felices en ellos
siempre ganan los héroes y caen los
villanos y siempre hay por lo menos un
personaje con el que te puedes
identificar
a mí me ayudaron a ponerle voz y rostro
a esta sombra oscura que siempre estaba
atrás de mí
en millones de películas podemos ver la
típica escena de un personaje haciendo
una decisión conflictuada en las locuras
del emperador los simpsons de ultimate
spider-man son sólo algunos de los
muchos programas en los que podemos ver
este tema
este esquema fue inicialmente creado por
sigmund freud
en este hay un ello unión y un superior
o en otras palabras un una
persona y un ángel
con ellos comencé a pensar en mi
pesimismo como el en mi hombro
que me hacía pensar en lo peor y en mi
ángel era ese miedo que me protegía de
lo que el me decía
el ello es la parte más profunda
primitiva e innata de nuestra persona
son todos nuestros deseos impulsos y las
necesidades primitivas del ser humano en
otras palabras es un que quiere
cubrir sus necesidades inmediatamente
sin importar las consecuencias
el yo es como un mediador entre nuestro
mundo interior y exterior es el
activista que debe cumplirlas los deseos
y demandas del ello y todo aquello que
existe que exige el superior
finalmente tenemos el superior que es
todo lo contrario al ello son nuestros
valores pensamientos morales 30 miento
estéticos es todo aquello que nuestra
cultura y nuestra sociedad quiere que
seamos o en otras palabras nuestro ángel
con pensamientos tan pesimistas de parte
de mí ello me ve imposible no pensar que
había algo mal en mí cuando estás
creciendo todos te dicen que no debes
escuchar este que siempre debes
de hacer lo que sea necesario para
mantenerte seguro pero que no debes
preocuparte que debes disfrutar mientras
puedas
pero en esos raros momentos en los que
la gente realmente trata de hablar
acerca de los temas de salud y tanto
transtornos mentales aunque se haga con
el mayor cuidado del mundo así es que al
hacerlo te llegas a identificar con
algunos de los síntomas de los que
hablan ya sea tristeza pérdida de
interés ansiedad sales pensando que tú
estás mal
pero te lo callas porque siempre te han
dicho que no es algo por lo que deberías
pasar
cuando yo anoté estos síntomas realmente
los reflexionen
pero seguiré siendo de las mejores de mi
clase sigue teniendo amistades que
seguramente durarían para toda la vida
y seguía teniendo la ligera esperanza
que mis pensamientos intrusivos no
durarían para siempre
así que no tenía sentido compartirlo con
nadie
cuando no te sientes bien con como
funcionas pero aún así lo hace
no ves la necesidad de preocupar a los
demás con tus problemas
en mi caso por mucho tiempo soy así con
el ángel sobre mi hombro peleando por
callar ese molesto viviendo con
esta parte de mí que en realidad no me
dejaba vivir pasaron evento dos
entrenamientos exámenes ciertas todo lo
que se puedan imaginar y poco a poco
todo lo que me disponía dejó de hacerlo
llegó el momento en el que deje de
disfrutar el voleibol un momento en el
que me di cuenta que las calificaciones
realmente no importan un momento en el
que las personas que yo consideraba mis
mejores amigos me traicionaron
pero aún no ha hecho pedazos no era lo
desconocido para mí no era la falta de
esperanza
por primera vez en mi vida este ángel se
había dado por vencido el lo
había aniquilado y con cada día esa
figura se apoderaba más de mí seguía
siendo todo lo que debía hacer solo
porque sabía que era lo que se suponía
que tenía que hacer
hasta que un día un amigo mío me dijo
tú eres mi modelo así
como pueden imaginar me quedé perpleja
obviamente no le dije estás loco no
tienes ni idea de lo que estaría
metiendo solo se lo agradeció
nunca me hubiera podido imaginar lo mal
que se siente que te alguien te diga que
quiere ser como tú cuando tú realmente
odias cómo funciona
pasaron varios días pero este momento se
quedó en mi mente
hasta que me llegó una epifanía
si es que sintiéndome de la peor manera
que me había sentido y siendo
completamente pesimista podía hacer
cosas que los demás querían hacer que
ellos admiraban
tal vez había una manera de sentirme
bien y hacer las cosas que yo quería
hacer
y tal vez y sólo tal vez es lo que yo
veía como mi más grande defecto me podía
ayudar a hacerlo
tengo que admitir que no fue un cambio
de mentalidad inmediato créanme que
hubiera amado que hubiera sido como en
las películas poder saltar a la parte
donde me encontraba a mí misma y en
contra de todo lo que se esperaba vivía
feliz para siempre
pero esta es la vida real el camino es
un millón de veces más largo y difícil
de lo que lo hacen parecer
así que después de unas cuantas semanas
de ver películas tristes y desoladoras
me levanté de mi cama me mira en el
espejo y vi ese que me había
estado acechando
esta vez no como un enemigo
sino como un aliado
aunque por mucho tiempo me quedé
estancada en mi miedo era momento de
tomarlo y convertirlo en un impulso para
mi vida
así que decidí que iba a hacer las cosas
diferentes
que cada vez que quisiera hacer algo y
pensar en una manera en la que podría
salir mal entonces pensaría en cómo
podría salir cien veces peor
aceptaría que si es una posibilidad que
eso pudiera llegar a pasar y me
arriesgaría
así que después de nueve años dejé de
jugar voleibol
un deporte que aunque en un momento me
hacía realmente feliz y sentir viva
en ese entonces ya no lo hacía
me separé de aquellos amigos que tan
sólo buscaba complacer por miedo dejar
de ser una buena amiga deje de ser
controlada por la irritante voz del ello
y deje de vivir mi vida para todos y
vivir una vida para mí
hoy todavía tengo ese en mi
hombro y el ángel que una vez se dio por
vencido nos puede volver a acompañar
esta vez creamos sueños y no parando los
aunque nunca van a desaparecer mis
miedos ya no me dominan y me permiten
dejar de vivir mi vida en automático
este cómico personaje que me echaba
ahora es mi mejor aliado
si uno que llega a hacer mi vida parecer
imposible en ciertos momentos pero que
me ha llevado a intentar y experimentar
lo que jamás me atreví a hacer
al crecer nos dicen que siempre le debes
de hacer caso al ángulo pero aunque
nunca te dicen es que mientras ese ángel
te mantiene a salvo es el el que
te saca de tu zona de confort
no estoy diciendo que es bueno hacer el
mal pero si adoptamos esa determinación
y atrevimiento hacia nuestro hacia
nuestros proyectos nuestros sueños
seremos imparables
pero esta no es una idea nueva joey norm
y nástic under miembros de la facultad
del western college en massachusetts
defienden el pesimismo a través de la
investigación con un enfoque crítico en
su libro el poder positivo del
pensamiento negativo
fernando rojas también explora este
concepto en la fuerza del optimismo
ellos lo denominan como pesimismo
defensivo y en sus investigaciones
afirman que alguien que adopta el
pesimismo defensivo está mejor preparado
para un fracaso ya que en su pensamiento
este fracaso ya es algo casi seguro
en otras palabras cuando te preparas
para lo peor
fácilmente te sorprendes agradablemente
y así es que llega a pasar lo peor ya te
preparaste para ello al bajar las
expectativas se reduce la ansiedad
si es que todos estos expertos le pueden
ver los beneficios al pesimismo
entonces por qué nosotros no
he vivido con esta mentalidad durante
los últimos tres años de mi vida la
comparación con los otros 15 no suena
como mucho pero durante esto se logrado
mucho más de lo que me lo que jamás hice
nunca creí que acoger el pesimismo fuera
una opción pero hoy lo hago y estoy
mejor al compañero para hacer cosas
nuevas
así que la próxima vez que tengas miedo
de hacer algo piensa en la peor manera
en la que podría pasar
porque los pesimistas siempre tenemos
razón o pueden sorprendernos
agradablemente
gracias